hi welcome my name is Andrea Russell and
I'm a program manager here at Google
welcome to cloud on-ear live webinars
from Google cloud we're here every
Tuesday recording live and today we're
going to be talking about insight and
how you can use your data to get more
insights to drive better marketing
decisions
perfect so I'm gonna be kicking it off
with just a great overview of Google
Cloud bigquery
and how you can use our tools to get
marketing insights and then I'll pass it
on to Jonathan Romero he'll be talking
about seven stars and their success
story using matil Ian and bigquery and
then lastly we'll have David Langdon
here to do a really cool demo of the
matil Ian ETL they'll be showing you how
easy to use the platform is and how
quickly you can go from setup all the
way to analysis in just like a few quick
minutes at the end we'll also have time
for questions but if you've got some
questions in the middle of the
presentation feel free to pop them into
the forum and we'll be here answering
questions live so with that I'll just
dive right in
and so when I first joined the team here
at Google cloud we were not only spent a
lot of time talking to customers and
what we kept hearing over and over is
that advertisers know that they have a
lot of data they understand that the
data is important but it's really really
challenging to link these datasets
together together and get any sort of
valuable insights so here at Google we
decided that we need to do something and
we started thinking about how we could
position ourselves to best help our
clients get the most value from their
data and even personally myself I came
from the advertising industry online
advertising I worked I worked at an
agency trading desk and I heard these
same challenges echoed over and over I
would spend a lot of time in Excel
sheets you know doing the lookups
merging data sets just so we could
deliver those insights to our clients so
I think it's safe to say that most
companies understand it's important to
get smarter about data and actually the
main goal is not just to be smarter with
data but to actually put the customer at
the center of everything that you do so
with that in mind I wanted to fast
forward a bit and think about at the end
of the presentation so if there are
three things that you leave this
presentation with there are three things
that I want you to leave this
presentation with and maybe think about
as you sort of hear from me and some of
our other partners the first is what are
the top three data silos that can you
could combine to create a better view of
your customer how can you understand
your customers journey better
the second is what new customer insights
can you unlock by combining your data
together and then the third is how can
you connect audience insights to drive
better media activation and better
performance so we know it's easy to
think about the problems but it's cut
it's much more difficult to get started
and so we I hope you we've inspired you
to take the first step in your data
journey but even taking a step back how
can we get more valuable insights from
your customers data we know that our
clients are generating tons of data
touchpoints I've heard one statistic
that there's over 900 customer touch
points in the data journey but how can
you break this down how can you start
making sense from this huge volume of
data and so one way that we like to
think about it is with this digital
marketing insights formula so if you
think about connections or making
connections across data then you get
insights and to break this down even a
little bit further you can think of an X
and y axis so if you have a blank grid
and you draw one data point on there
that doesn't actually tell you much so
you don't actually know what's going on
you don't know what that means and if
you add two or three additional data
points that still doesn't tell you much
what's really valuable is the lines that
you draw in between the data and when
you start to add those additional data
sources the connections are the really
important part it's the real true source
of power and so in order to see the
relationships between the data points
you have to create those connections and
when those connections increase then you
create a three-dimensional picture of
your data and you can start to
understand your customers more you can
start to create a richer and more robust
view of your customer which helps you to
customize and personalize their journey
and create a really unique customer
experience but here's the problem many
of the tools that marketers use exist in
isolation there's some really great
tools out there but it's really
challenging to make connections when
you're using several different tools
that don't talk to each other it's as if
all of these tools were living in the
separate desert island with no boat no
bridge just hanging out by themselves
the island that stuff might be great but
if you're all alone it's not that fun
so we've heard from some of our
customers that they use over 30 separate
marketing tools to deliver marketing
type activities online offline anything
that you would need to do with marketing
but in addition to marketing
there's also customer data and that data
can live in different silos your CRM
data your ERP data your billing data and
all of this could be enriching your
marketing data to create that fuller
3-dimensional view of your customer so
if you want to unlock the power of your
data you need more than just a new tool
or one new thing you need a whole
customer data platform a holistic vision
that can help you to create the
connection between your data points and
pull out the nuggets of data to help you
personalize the experience for your
customers and integrating your data
doesn't just drive a technical advantage
like it's one thing to say you're using
the newest tools and they're fast and
they're awesome these tools are actually
critical to staying competitive and the
companies that are doing that tend to
see huge benefits in sales profits and
margins so why Google and I love it when
companies come to this question because
it's really simple so Google was built
as a data company we've spent the past
18 years developing advertising tools we
have a huge advertising business and we
did that because we needed
infrastructure that was robust that was
scaleable that could manage a lot of
data and there wasn't anything else out
there so we really built it ourselves
and we really aligned that with our with
our mission of organizing the world's
information and making it universally
accessible and useful we also have a
really secure infrastructure we take
privacy and security seriously and our
customers you know put our trust in us
our business depends on that in fact
we've hired over 500 engineers just to
focus on security alone and at the end
of the day security and infrastructure
is great but for you what really matters
is getting the insights faster so we
have pre-built connectors that can bring
your data directly into bigquery which
reduces your overall time to set up and
bigquery alone can run some of the
queries that you would normally run in
minutes or hours in seconds
additionally we want you to focus on the
results not just the technology so we
have a whole no ops architecture which
is unique among cloud providers this
means that you can set up your data
pipeline you can bring your data in and
immediately start to run a query without
the IT overhead that you would need to
use if you're using other providers so
how do you get started I think the best
way to think about this is to think
about the data sets that you want to
bring in and then think about how you
can get them into bigquery one great
starting point is with the Google
advertising data sources so we have a
service called the bigquery data
transfer service which automatically
brings in data from YouTube double-click
AdWords automatically into bigquery in a
scheduled manner multiple times a day
and aside from this transfer service we
have native connectors with G through 60
so you can bring in that really rich
site site analytics data and also
firebase you can bring in your mobile
app data once your data is in bigquery
then you can pretty much immediately
start querying it would have been query
and start to get insights you can always
also leverage our machine learning tools
so we have cloud data lab which makes it
easy to get set up and start creating
your own models you could use tensorflow
or our machine learning engine or any of
our other pre-built machine learning
api's you could also use some
visualization tools so partners like
tableau looker
or even connectors like google sheets or
other spreadsheets bigquery makes it
easy to share and you choose who has
access to the data when so we like to
think about doing marketing analytics on
Google cloud through the lens of the
data lifecycle so we have collect
transform and analyze and we know that
most companies need to do this before
they can get value out of their data and
we have tools that help support you
every single step of the way so in order
to unlock the power of your data and
create the meaningful connections that
start to tell a bigger bigger story it's
important to set your base up right and
make sure you have a strong data
foundation
so this is really just the beginning of
the journey Google cloud offers a data
platform that's architectural II
different from most other sass platforms
in that it allows you to integrate in
create huge datasets many different data
sources in a scaleable open-ended way we
have open architecture which makes it
easy to bring in many different data
sources you can merge those datasets you
can use machine learning the result is a
platform that it's flexible and powerful
that allows you to really respond to
what your customers need and we like to
think of this as the era of assistance
meaning that customers want to have
personalized unique experiences and when
you use your data to tell that story it
makes it easier for your company to do
that so I hope you've enjoyed that
overview next up I'm gonna invite
Jonathan Romero to tell a little bit
about seven stars in their success story
with Google bigquery thanks
okay thanks Andrea really great stuff so
I'm Jonathan my work at the seven stars
based in London and we are the UK's most
successful and largest independent media
agency so we're a full-service agency
doing everything from TV and radio to
the whole digital spectrum and we've
been around for several years now and
growing very quickly and now as we've
grown we've also seen a big increase in
the amount of data that is available to
us and the demand from clients for
sophisticated data projects so we've
really had to look at our options for
managing that data and ensuring that we
can effectively activate it and make it
an asset for our clients and internal
teams so today I'm going to start just
with a little bit about the journey that
led us to mozillian and and how we use
it when I started at the 7 stars one of
the core requirements was to overhaul
the reporting solution the traditionally
was based on Excel with a lot of manual
data extraction from various platforms
adding it into Excel and using pivot
tables and things like that to to
produce the final dashboard this was
obviously a very manual process taking a
lot of time and the outputs are not
particularly good so we wanted to
automate as much as possible save a lot
of time and improve the visuals in one
go so we looked at various options to do
that there are a lot of solutions in the
marketplace that offer kind of one-stop
shop digital marketing data and
reporting solutions and so we looked
around to these services but nothing
really gave us the flexibility that we
wanted each of our clients has very
different requirements and what works
from one client doesn't necessarily work
for another and it was doing this
research phase that we kept hearing
about bigquery and GCP and we were very
interested in the double-click data
transfer services that Google are
offering and we're also hearing more and
more about clients wanting to upgrade to
GA 360 with the bigquery export so
bigquery was becoming a very viable
solution for us
it was then quite easy to make that
decision to move to bigquery and put all
that data into bigquery it offered
everything we were looking for it's
scalable we you know maintenance-free
basically and we could pull in the data
from all our Google stack advertising
platforms hmm
that left us with a hole for various
other platforms like Facebook and
Twitter Mattila niz one one solution
that will actually bring data in from
those from those platforms when there
are several other third-party providers
that will we'll hook up to to various
other advertising platforms and pulled
the data straight into bigquery so it's
really easy and stress-free to get your
data into bigquery when that was a big
bonus for us and one of the key and the
key things that led us to bigquery so
now you've got all your data in bigquery
what do you do with it how do you
activate it how do you make sense of it
all there's a lot of different data sets
different schemas not particularly
user-friendly if you're not a technical
team so certainly for us using the DCM
data transfer files with billions of
billions of rows it's not something you
can directly work with like a tableau or
a dates to do so and bigquery itself is
is great for writing queries and getting
that immediate result but for reporting
what we needed to have in place was a
replicable process these transformation
jobs that we needed to build to
aggregate and clean the data for use in
reporting and other things and we didn't
have a big team of SQL experts we didn't
have a team of data engineers available
to do that for us so we really needed a
tool to kind of bridge that gap for us
and this is where matil ioan comes in
and we we stumble upon metallian at a
gtp summit in London and within five
minutes of a demo of material we had
decided that this was a really great
tool for us something that could help us
in in the the problem that we had
so we signed up we got it we got it
going and within you know within a week
or so we were very comfortable with it
we could do everything we needed to do
so joining different data sets together
aggregating putting various string
calculations and other kind of
calculations to to really normalize the
data that we were working with so we
really could do everything we needed to
do and take that billion row of data
table down to maybe 30 40 thousand which
is much more manageable and lastly
really the the great thing then is also
be able to schedule these transformation
jobs so if you have consistent data
coming into bigquery like within the
data transfer files which are coming in
every every so often you can then
schedule your battalion jobs to coincide
with that and you have a consistently
updated data set for you so it's really
great to structure that day to get it
ready for the reporting the the key
really is getting that lean and kissed
and consistent data set but you get much
better performance from things like
tableau and in Google Data studio where
you've got a your data set up and ready
to go so we've been manage to build at
least 10 or so custom reports and since
starting up with material saving
hundreds of hours really in in in work
hours and letting that those people who
would normally be working with Excel to
actually go and do other things and and
be much more effective and so and I
think finally it's also important to
note that well the reporting requirement
was the main driver for us initially
it's actually not necessarily where
you're going to get or your value from
since we've been using matil ian a
management of the big raw data sets we
get from from google you can then start
to look at things like advanced audience
segmentation things you can't do in DCMA
or GA interfaces so you can get a much
more specific and detailed
segmentation of your customers and
specifically if you're using DBM for
remarketing then
the PLU process which takes those
audiences and from bigquery and puts
them into puts them into DBM that PLU
process can be automated through three
million which is a huge time-saver
because that's currently a manual
process if you're not using something
like cotillion and then working with the
GA 360 data export which is very tricky
data set to to work with at times so
bringing metallian and putting that on
top is is really really beneficial we
recently had a client brief to build an
attribution model on their 360 data and
we were able to use metallian to
actually transform that data and put the
model in so very versatile tool and the
benefits to us have been really
tremendous so I'd like to thank Google
and Mattila and now I think it's David
from Attilan to come and give us a demo
hi hello to everyone so as Jonathan just
said I'm David Langton from Italian I've
drawn somewhat the short straw today I'm
going to be doing a live demo I
practiced it twice and I'm currently
running at a 50 percent success rate so
whether this goes smoothly or terribly I
hope you'll still get some value out of
it so let me switch over to the to the
demo excellent so what you'll do if
you've already got a web browser you can
sign up for GCP you can get bigquery
running and you can head to Google cloud
launcher and get your own copy of
Mattila and running that's what you're
looking at right now and I've just
started to build a job and the scenario
we're going to run through today is just
to take some data out of a couple of
different silos bring it back together
and and make something out of that you
can already see on screen that I'm
loading my Salesforce contacts and the
first thing I'm going to do is just
duplicate that so that we can also load
the Salesforce account data now I'm
doing that in what we call an
orchestration job we'll have
transformation jobs as well and we'll
come to that later the important point
is that we do despite saying we're an
ETL tool we're actually doing the
extract and the load all in one go in
these orchestration jobs and we'll
transform the data in place on bigquery
afterwards so the data won't have to
leave bigquery again just to get reciate
and cleansed okay so the way this works
any component you see on a screen
highlight it work your way through the
properties connect it up so that it runs
at the right time during you flow and
you should be good to go so I've just
taken a copy of the Salesforce contacts
job I'm just going to switch that now to
load the Salesforce account data
now the account data has different
columns so that's not valid yet and all
I need really is the ID and the name
from there the other thing I'm going to
do is quickly change the name of the
output table otherwise we'll be
overwriting our contacts and I'll just
wile out to the start component perfect
so I mentioned another source of data
this is Salesforce we could also be
loading from all sorts of internet
systems CRM systems ERP systems over and
above any data you may already be
transferring into bigquery by a Google's
own services so what I need here really
I've got some I've got a data file in
cloud storage and I want to bring that
in and match it to my Salesforce
contacts now I could do that by bringing
on a create table with the right
structure and then followed by a load
what I'm actually gonna do is use a tool
that we've got which will do all of that
for me in a wizard so that it just makes
it a little bit a little bit simpler so
I'll drag that and drop it onto the
canvas and I will find my sample data
file there we go
and rather than having to do a lot of
manual effort now based on a sample of a
number of rows we'll just guess what the
appropriate table definition for that is
it's pulled the header out and give me
some sensible column names it's detected
that it's a CSV I could carry on and
make some modifications and maybe do a
test but for the purposes of this demo
I'm pretty sure that's going to work and
I hit OK and just continue now at that
point it looks like that job is almost
done
my tiled storage load seems a little bit
unhappy I'm getting some failures there
it's actually just because the target
table doesn't exist or doesn't exist yet
in fact when I run this job in a moment
it will exist and then that will that
will work just fine so let's run that
now
excellent so that's going to bring in
two tables from Salesforce and also some
data from Google cloud store there's a
little bit more to do in this job and
I'm going to come back and finish it off
in a few minutes time but right now I'm
going to track now I'm going to switch
over to the transformation job where
we're going to try and make sense of
some of this data
I've already started it and I'm not
going to go through the details here but
essentially I'm just joined in those
Salesforce contacts and account back
together what we really want is to bring
those two silos together though so what
I'm going to do is bring in that data we
just load it in from cloud storage and
join that as well so I'm just gonna
bring in a table important and figure it
quickly write one and we'll just bring
in all the columns from that file I'm
then I'm gonna need to join that to my
Salesforce data and for this particular
analysis my main table is that marketing
data I am interested in each and every
individual that was targeted in this
campaign and that's the file that's
telling me who was targeted what I'm
interested in is how many of those
targets ended up being Salesforce
accounts with a contact that matches
as I say it's a left join so that we're
interested in all the marketing data
whether or not there was a contact now I
need a joint condition there this is a
sequel expression I can use the UI to
build that because what I'm really
interested in the email address in that
marketing file equals the email address
of the linked contact in Salesforce
you'll also see that as I'm building
that expression it's being sent to
bigquery to be validated so that if I've
got any errors at this stage I'll know
before on the job not after and the only
thing I need now is to just bring the
columns in and be in pressed for time
I'm just gonna hit at all now I've done
quite a lot of work at this point
without really knowing whether any of
this is working with those files really
loaded from Salesforce and we saw a
preview of 50 rows of the marketing data
but what we really want to know is have
a configured everything correctly
now what you'd normally do in an ETL
tool is just run it look at the output
when you spot a problem go back to the
beginning and run it again we've got a
little bit of a different flow here
because all the data is in bigquery
anyway I can debug my transformations
just by running some queries against the
data that's already there using the code
that's already being generated by
Mattila
so just as a sanity check I'm gonna set
a filter on this join and make sure it
can find a record that I know should be
in there so let's take the last name I'm
gonna set that equal to our CTO s last
name he will almost definitely appear in
this data because he's always a sample
record and then I can get a preview of
the data and the row count without
actually running any queries or creating
any physical tables so we've got 10,000
rows coming in there and we found the
one row we were looking for which tells
us the right amount of data is there and
all the joins must be working for us to
go get this far okay just a little bit
more that's still raw data we might want
to aggregate that so I'm gonna throw on
a quick aggregate
but also a calculation what we're really
interested in here is whether that
marketing data actually led to the
creation of an account
so we're going to add a quick expression
to say whether the campaign was a
success that's going to be a little bit
more sequel now if we managed to find
the company in Salesforce we can pick
any any field coming from Salesforce
really for this if that's null then
that's not a success otherwise it is now
you'll know your about data a lot better
than I will
you'll also recognize that this is very
simplified and very idealized scenario
but hopefully it gives you an idea of
what's going on here
I've now got a 0 or 1 flag on every
single record based on whether that
converted there's no areas so let's flow
that into my Ankara gate and this is
where you can really start to get some
powerful things we group by the campaign
name what we're primarily interested in
is how many people we emailed so we can
just count the records for that and we
can sum those zero one flags to give us
a meaningful number of how many of those
were response respondent and at this
point I can also go back see how many
day is going to make it to that point in
the flow and have a look at it as well
this has been very highly aggregated
down to just a handful of campaigns and
you can see that email in a couple of
thousand people for each variation and
we're getting response rates of just
under a thousand if any of you guys are
getting that sort of response rate from
an email campaign do get in touch
because I'd love to hear about that one
last thing I'm gonna write that out to a
physical table so that we can share that
with other people without giving them
access to all that raw data with
potentially sensitive things in there
give that quick name
I don't know overwrite any of the tables
I've got just a new one
I'm going to run this job in a second
but first I'm going to make it part of a
repeatable flow so that this can be run
repeatedly and know that you're going to
get the same results each time so I'm
gonna drag my transform into the
orchestration job and then just put an
end in to make sure that all my
prerequisites depth happen first before
that transformation happens so when my
contacts are loaded and my accounts are
loaded and my cloud storage load
completes then I run my transform and
I'm just going to right click and run
this demo job now interactively that
could of course be scheduled it could be
triggered on the basis of that file
landed in the bucket and triggered that
way also an API call could kick that off
and that will now run to completion
just crossing an extra pair of fingers
so far so good
excellent and now all my results are in
bigquery as well as the source data
which could now be removed and we have a
repeatable float for doing that end to
end every time those underlying data
sources change I hope you found that
useful and informative and I'll
definitely invite you all to hang around
for the next minute I'm going to turn
over to a Q&A session and I hope we've
got plenty of good questions coming in
for that thank you
you
well thanks for that great demo David
that was awesome
and they actually did went pretty it did
pretty well so we've got a few questions
from the audience the first question is
what kind of data can I store in Google
Cloud can I include personal information
like customer customer names and email
addresses so the answer is yes you can
store any type of data that you want we
actually have a few different data
products we have in query which is our
data warehouse we also have spanner and
Google Cloud Storage which can also
store unstructured data you are able to
include personal information PII
customer names email addresses we are a
secure platform but it's up to you to
decide what you want to do with your own
data the second question is can Google
Cloud integrate with my on-premise
systems or other marketing systems and
other clouds the answer is yes Google
Cloud can integrate so you absolutely
can write your own code to integrate
with your on-premise systems any other
systems that you have in the cloud like
I mentioned we have our Google cloud
service which you can use to help upload
data in between and you can also use
partners who can help to integrate data
and help that data move on prem to the
cloud yeah indeed and in the metallian
demo you just saw I only very briefly
expanded some of the folders full of
connect as we do for all sorts of
systems some of those running in the
cloud some of them on premise we also
have a technology which allows you to
map any API into a tabular format and
load that as if it was a set of related
tables so if you've invested heavily in
relational technology unless you get the
most out of that and the best out of
your staff who already understand that
by just mapping that yeah yeah flexible
solution awesome so you've got lots of
connectors in lots of connectors out
it's awesome so the next question is I'm
in a specialized industry can I use
google cloud why yes you can so we
actually have tons of one that tons but
we have a few specialized vertical
solutions so for example healthcare IOT
Internet of Things finance we also have
government specific solutions we're very
interested in learning more about our
industries specific solutions and
platforms then you can navigate to cloud
google.com and check out our solutions
page we've got little tabs with tons of
information on their architecture
solutions tons of information about the
industry and then the last question so
if I use the bigquery data transfer
service or mozillian do I get any extra
information that's not already in the
public reporting API yes so you actually
or actually the answer is no you
actually don't get any extra in for
information that's not right that's not
included in the api's what happens is we
just pull the information from directly
from the source where it's coming from
so for for example the YouTube API
presents the data I think every day the
DFP API has a different cadence and we
are just pulling that data in and doing
that transformation for you the
advantage of this data is that it's a no
op setup so literally in five clicks you
can bring your data in from those
sources and you can have it ready to for
analysis without having to maintain that
ETL now it's just kept up to date at all
times isn't it so you've never got to
worry about that again it's always just
there when you need it yeah exactly
yeah matter of fact all right well thank
you guys so much for joining it's been
great to have you and we'll hope to see
you next Tuesday thanks
you